and the robots take our jobs
what will humans do I think the obvious
answer is have more sex we will become
shepherds again and it will be our job
to care for and tend to our flock of
robots well I think that that's kind of
a pretty dark vision of the future
I actually think about the helping
humanity in saving lives well I feel
like it's already happening I think both
presidential candidates are actually AI
I think as they augment them there's an
opportunity there for all of us to
explore that next level of what we can
all be so certainly the progress of AI
like every technological progress is
going to displace jobs but this is not a
new phenomenon we've been used to this
is the Industrial Revolution I
fundamentally believe robots are not
gonna take a job let's imagine a robot
helping an elderly person at home that
doesn't replace a nurse
it actually lets the nurse not worry
about washing maybe helping the person
off it lets the nose worry about the
health of the person maybe their mental
health is at risk I'm sure we will come
up with more things to do more jobs to
have in the future if the robots end up
taking those jobs and there are
literally no jobs for us to do ever I
think we'll all just go sit on a beach
and think about life's big questions
like why does bacon taste so good
clearly the only thing left for humans
to do will be to take care of the robots
which will ultimately be bad for the
robots because I kind of feel like the
care will be kind of slack it'll be bad
they'll be like poor maintenance the
robots are gonna get mad they won't
really be able to come up with robots
that can take care of themselves because
then those robots will need human
maintenance so ultimately poor
maintenance will be the demise of all
the
in the world the humans will once again
triumph and go back to the lifestyle
we've grown accustomed to